hallo mein nameom meine Damen und Herren
ich sitze hier gemeinsam mit Sirio und
wir rufen heute Leute an über unser
Handy werden dabei allerdings richtig
laute Musik auf unseren Kopfhörern haben
s dass wir nicht hören was sie sagen und
dann gucken wir ob wir richtig antworten
auf jed Fall zuerst jemand ich ruf
Sandra an ja hi
hi ja alles gut bei
dir hörst du gerade
Musik ich höre
dich was ist Red mal lauter wie laut den
noch keine Ahnung was zockst du da ich
zock gerade
du was laberst du ich hab gerade
gegessen erst W oder wo willst du hin la
hier Sandra
ne ja
gut
bei
dir musst du W was vorspielen oder
was
ich
ja keine
Ahnung junge
C hast du noch
Kopfschmerzen weg aufgelegt warum du
mein ob ge Kopfschmerzen
hast ru jetzt
R
[Musik]
was hast Du
getan egal auf jeden Fall ru mir Tim was
geht
Bro hi hallo Sirio alles gut J bei dir
ja ja klar
Bro zu
hören ja ich auch guck Fußball hab
gefrühstückt geil geil ja geil ja bei
mir selber eigentlich war Fußball kicken
nee diger kann ich heute nicht ja hab
gekickt ganzen Tag du hast gekickt und
du hast auch gekickt ich habe auch
gekickt ja ja geil nice gehst du gleich
und hast du gegessen diger was ist dein
Plan Alter was hast du ja ich habe un
normal gut
gegessen bring auf Punkt was kann ich
für dich
tun was nach fußballpi kicken junge
Alter hallo keine
Ahnung wasst
du die Kopfhörer die sind hier willst
jetzt haben oder nicht ja die Kopfhörer
meinst du ja nein
ne nein nein nein nein nein ne ja okay
alles gut Bro ja das freut mich super
dann warte warte warte warte warte ja
warum wie warum was warum du KF jetzt
habe ich hier rausgesucht jetzt scheiß
drauf scheiß drauf ja super war so
Komis hast du nicht schon
gegessen
ich
ist alles okay bei dir morgen können wir
ich kann morgen ich habe jetzt die
Kopfhörer rausgesucht di ich hab
bisschen Kopfschmerzen du hast
Kopfschmerzen okay ich habe ein auf die
Birne
bekommen okay ja ich Kopf gestoßen
Bruder schon bisschen neben der Spur
keine Ahnung lass mich kurz überlegen
nee ich habe keine Zeit okay super komm
geh
weg ja hau rein wir rufen jusf an weil
eigentlich mussste schst bei der Podcast
Aufnahme sein und die warten schon aber
dann rufen wir jusf jetzt einfach weil
der muss rangehen ho hi seid ihr
da ich bin gleich da
okay ja ja wir sind
ready bei dir auch gut ja ja
ja ja ja
ja genau ja du bist auch zu Hause ne ich
bin auf gerade auf Sofa super super Ich
freue mich ja
super bequem
echt stimmt
man
M M ja wegen der Uhrzeit also se schon
spät kann sein ja
ja okay was
ist warum warum morgen meine Zähne sind
kaputt und ich habe ich habe richtig
Bauchschmerzen vom Essen krass
krass
Sandra wo die ist meinst du oder was
sandra ist die ist mit dem Auto
in ich glaube 5 Minuten ist sie da im
Parkhaus und dann würde ich jetzt auch
so ein Z Minuten los ich habe gerade
noch so die Autogrammkarten die dingsk
Karten fertig gemacht für Podcast also
ich komme jetzt auch rüber bist du schon
da du kannst dir nicht vorstellen wie
dieses Studio gemie hat weil wir so
lange nicht drin
waren Bo stinkt noch im
Studio
ne ne ich habe seit 30 Minuten Fenster
auf sperwe also ich rie immer noch was
30 30 Uhr ja genau 30
Uhr ich habe Fenster aufgemacht auf 7:30
uh bei dir mach Fenster auf im Studio
okay
gut super Lüft mal richtig durch da den
ganzen Laden ich komme jetzt rüber weiß
ich lauf los jetzt einfach super super
ich fre geil ja liebe grüß okay hau rein
ja bis gleich
C warum der sagt einfach es hat im
Studio gemüffel wie du auf einmal weißt
ganz genau
stinkt e bist du schon losgegangen nein
ne ich lauf gerade
hin e warte mal auf 5
Minuten diger was ist denn mit dir
warum J warum redest du so komisch ich
war noch essen ich habe geredet beim
Essen warum und Kopfschmerzen auch
bisschen die Gruppe D doch ein bisschen
länger
dauert meine
[Musik]
Uhr ich habe in meinen Kopf
gestoßen
Lua
ja kannst du jetzt in die Gruppe
schreiben D noch bisschen später
wird war ich schreibe
dir schreib mal
okay ja schreib mal okay in 5 Minuten
Parkhaus 5 Minuten maximal also ich
laufe jetzt los ich muss gerade noch mal
kurz eben anrufen mich gerade angerufen
aber ich bin sofort da okay bis gleich
okay top bis
gleich okay ja okay Leute das war vom
Video Sir hat ein blaues Auge uns
Freunde sind sauer auf uns und die
Hälfte geht nichtan weil sie am trinken
ist hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen
falls ja cool falls nein kann ich
verstehen